I'm currently working on a video essay that like puts all of
this information into perspective, but it's going to take me
a little bit. So, I know that like a lot of this is kind of all
over the place, but I'm that's I've been working on it for a
couple of days now and uh been re researching for it ever since
this [__] came out. So, yeah, just be patient. I
will be coming out with a full [__] fledged video
essay that will be claiming that her article is debunked. But
uh you know till then
people. So what would happen is if I if they are a fiscal sponsor,
okay, if that's the case, we would have chorus right here. And
so chorus would be in the middle. Then we would have uh 1630
up above them. Okay? And then we would have content creators
down here. So chorus would be paying 1630 for them to take all
donations and everything. So if we have a bunch of people over
here, these people are going to donate to
Chorus by donating to 1630.
1630 is going to hold Chorus's money here and then they're going
to give that money to the content creators. Meaning that technically
it's Chorus's money. So Chorus is still the one who's paying
the content creators. So Chorus pays 1630 and the content creators.
1630 is still shady as [__] On top of them restricting
what they creators can talk about. There's no evidence they restrict
what their can talk about. The contract that was shown to us
literally says that it's under booking on like who they can and
can't talk to. And then outside of that, there was just no other
evidence that they restricted what they could or couldn't talk
about. There was like there was just no evidence for this. If
that was true, then why won't Brian publish it? Publish the contract.
Again, that it's not normally how it works. They don't just publish
contracts, but there have been other people who have given their
contracts to lawyers, and those lawyers have come out and said
that there's nothing in this that says that they can't talk about
this. And we've seen parts of the contract that actually show
us what like uh
that what what it is that it does say. They've published like
some sections of it. Brian would be stupid to give them a contract.
Well, again, uh there is a claim that a girl and her lawyer have
sent wired
uh a a a demand of retractions. Uh 15 retractions. I'm currently
working on a video essay that like puts all of this information
into perspective, but it's going to take me a little bit. So,
I know that like a lot of this is kind of all over the place,
but I'm that's I've been working on it for a couple of days now
and uh been re researching for it ever since this [__]
came out. So, yeah, just be patient. I will be coming out with
a full [__] fledged video essay that will be claiming
that her article is debunked. But uh you know till